marie viviane est une senior active
après de nombreuses années dans la vente
au marché du parc floral à fort de
france
elle décide à 50 ans de créer son
entreprise de vente de vêtements et
d'accessoires
aujourd'hui à 65 ans pas question de
penser retraite chaînes de commerce la
retraite vous n'y pensez pas pour
maintenant vu mon âge il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui sont déjà à la retraite et
moi même je me suis décidée lens est
toujours dans le commerce
je suis contente au contraire de sortir
tous les jours de m'habiller de sortir
vous venu travailler rester à la maison
ça donne un jeu vous pourrez faire venir
la veille malgré les difficultés de la
profession
marie viviane garde le sourire depuis
plusieurs années la gérante a du mal à
remplir les stocks de son magasin pour y
parvenir l'association pour le droit à
l'initiative économique lui vient en
aide financièrement nouvelle ça se passe
bien un petit peu un petit peu difficile
les deux actions principales de cette
association sont l'aide au financement à
la création d'entreprises mais aussi
l'accompagnement des entrepreneurs en ce
mois d'octobre
l'association met l'accent sur les
seniors il y a pas que les jeunes de la
nouvelle génération qui peuvent créer
leur entreprise
quand vous avez plus de 45 ans vous avez
des expériences vous avez des
compétences
vous avez aussi peut-être une plus
grande confiance en vous sur certains
plans et puis vous savez ce que vous
voulez et ce que vous ne voulez plus
et du coup on a quand même pas mal de
gens qu'on rencontre qui nous disent
d'un voilage et +45 ans et c'est aussi
le moment où j'ai envie de réaliser mon
rêve
la doyenne de nos clients en 2018 avait
79 ans et c'est une dame que nous allons
financer par la première fois pour son
activité l'année dernière sept cent
quarante personnes ont bénéficié de
l'aide de l'adie pour la création de
leur entreprise
parmi elles 39 % étaient des seniors